America's Got Talent winner grace Vander  Waal gets the surprise of a lifetime  from one of her pop idols oh my gosh oh  my gosh oh my gosh oh my gosh grace you  know what I predict for you I think you  are the next Taylor Swift grace made a  huge first impression on her judges  during her audition but she also won  over Taylor Swift throughout her journey  on Friday the 12 year old singer shared  an adorable video of a gift she received  from Swift and her uncontrollable  excitement grace captioned the cute clip  quote words cannot explain how honored I  am for this thank you so much Taylor  Swift it seems like Grace's victory on  the reality competition show has finally  come full circle I think the world is  gonna know your name